tonight
this entire show is basically going to
be one long recap of one very long week
and
and one event in particular meaning that
sadly there is going to be no time
to talk about trump insisting that the
un was laughing with him
and not at him which it absolutely
wasn't
nor is there gonna be time to delve into
what was clearly the most fun story of
the week
this all the philadelphia flyers have a
new mascot and fans are saying
what the that's seven foot tall gritty
pretty unveiled today in front of group
of kids probably scarred for life
yeah yeah those kids should be scarred
for life gritty is horrific
every single photo of him is appalling i
mean look at this one
that is a nightmare how about this one
that is simply psychotic
gritty looks like the end result of the
orange mcdonald's fry guy hooking up
with grimace and
we've been over this a million times
before on this show if you're a
mcdonald's mascot
you do not have sex with another
your genetics are too similar and their
kids always turn out wings
very very weird and incidentally it's
not like gritty has
any business being a hockey mascot
apparently he hasn't really figured out
how to navigate on the ice yet he fell
multiple times in his debut last night
the pittsburgh penguins tweeting lol
okay
to which gritty responded sleep with one
eye open
tonight bird holy gritty calm down
they're just engaging in some inter-team
banter and you've gone straight to i
will murder you in your sleep
and look there is absolutely nothing
that i would love to do more tonight
than
than talk about gritty all night long
from the fact that he's
already done a kim kardashian style
photo shoot
to the fact that and this is true
someone has already got an actual tattoo
of him on their body interestingly that
someone
jimmy carter unfortunately though the
fun we just had
must now stop because instead we need to
talk about brett kavanaugh supreme court
nominee and walking crushed beer can
now on thursday christine blasey ford
who was accused kavanaugh of sexually
assaulting her in 1982 came before the
senate judiciary committee to deliver
some powerful testimony
i am here today not because i want to be
i am terrified i am here because i
believe it is my civic duty
to tell you what happened to me while
brett kavanaugh and i were in high
school
right and she did just that describing
in detail detail her recollection of how
a drunk cavanaugh
pinned her down tried to remove her
clothing and put his hand over her mouth
when she tried to scream she insisted
that this could not possibly be
a case of mistaken identity because she
was 100 certain
that it was him and after her opening
statement she then took questions which
sometimes took an odd turn like when the
prosecutor to whom the republicans had
outsourced their responsibilities
seized on a polygraph test that ford had
passed
did you pay for the polygraph yourself
don't i don't i don't think so okay
do you know who did pay for the
polygraph not yet no
i believe you said it hasn't been paid
for yet
is that correct
let me put an end to this mystery her
lawyers have paid for her polygraph
as is routine wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa slow your roller as
is routine don't you try and brush her
question aside
she just cracks this case wide open
she found the missing piece of the
puzzle specifically a puzzle that reads
who cares now ford's testimony
was brave and compelling and seemed to
affect many on the committee including
republican senator orrin hatch who chose
to express his admiration
in a far from ideal way have you found
dr ford credible
well it's too early to say i i don't i
don't think she's incredible i think
she's an
attractive good witness but it's
way early what do you mean very
attractive sir
oh in other words
she's pleasing oh no no
no no pleasing
you should not use the word pleasing to
describe a sexual assault survivor
painfully recounting one of the worst
moments of her life you honestly
shouldn't really use it to describe
anything maybe
maybe watching milk mix into your coffee
except you know what
not even then because the moment you say
watching this milk is pleasing
you come off like a creepers waiting for
everyone to leave the room so he can
his coffee
the point is by lunchtime on thursday it
honestly seemed
that kavanaugh's nomination could be
finished even fox news was implying as
much
this was extremely emotional extremely
raw and extremely credible and
nobody could listen to her deliver those
words and talk about the assault and the
impact
it had had on his life on her life and
not have the
her heart go your heart go out to her
this is a disaster for the republicans
that is fox news calling ford's
testimony a disaster for the republicans
and not like one of those puerto rico
disasters you know this time one they
might actually care about
but then then came cavanaugh's testimony
and it is worth looking at it in detail
tonight because in every regard it could
not have been more different from ford's
for starters while she was remarkably
composed in discussing traumatic details
kavanaugh came straight out of the gate
weird in his opening statement
not just denying all her allegations but
almost breaking down
while attempting to paint a foxy image
of his time in high school
i worked out with other guys at tobin's
house
[Applause]
he was the great quarterback on our
football team
and his dad ran workouts yeah
he's crying at the memory of lifting
weights at his friend tobin's house
i hate to say it but i'm starting to
think that men might be too emotional
for the supreme court
also also also
he'd be he'd be really pretty if he just
smiled more
and it wasn't just memories of a high
school quarterback that was making him
tear up
i've always had a lot of close female
friends
i remember talking almost every night it
seemed to my friends amy
or julie
or kristen or karen or suzanne or maura
or megan or nikki
the list goes on okay that's not
testimony though is it that is a
plaintive spoken word cover of mambo
number five
i remember my friends angela pamela
sandra and rita
and as i continue you know they're
getting sweeter
[Applause]
but when kavanaugh was not choking back
tears he was starting to get noticeably
angry arguing that he was the victim of
a giant conspiracy
this allegation was unleashed and
publicly deployed
over dr ford's wishes
and then and then as no doubt was
expected
if not planned came a long series
of false last-minute smears designed to
scare me
and drive me out of the process before
any hearing occurred
crazy stuff gangs illegitimate children
fights on boats in rhode island i mean
come on
do i seem like exactly the type of
person who would get into a fight on a
boat in rhode island
seriously you tell me when you picture a
fight
on a boat in rhode island do you just
picture two of me
yelling at each other at exactly this
pitch and volume is that what you say
that if you wanted my haircut you would
tell your barber to give you the
fight on a boat in rhode island well i
would like to see you say that to my
face on a boat in rhode island
and that's all i have to shout about
that you
i'll see you on the water
and remember remember
what you've just seen was him reading
from a prepared statement
it got even stranger once he started
taking questions
did you consume alcohol during your high
school years yes we drank beer
uh my friends and i the boys and girls
yes we drank beer i liked beer
still like beer we drank beer the
drinking age as i noted was 18
so the seniors were legal senior year in
high school people were legal
to drink and we yeah we drank beer and i
said sometimes
sometimes probably had too many beers
and sometimes other people had too many
beers
we drank beer we like beer yeah i get
that i
do i um i get that loud and clear
brett's but but the question
isn't really do you like beer is it it's
how much
do you like it just like how the
question in jeffrey dahmer's trial
wasn't
do you like people it was do you like
people to a really problematic extent
and when pressed on his drinking
cavanaugh became either dismissive or
outright hostile and it was at those
moments you got a real sense of who this
man
actually is what do you consider to be
too many beers
i don't know uh you know we
whatever the chart says i like beer i
don't know if you like beer
senator or not um what do you like to
drink next one is
senator what do you like judge you're
saying there's never been a case where
you
drank so much that you didn't remember
what happened the night before or part
of what happened that's
you're asking about yeah blackout i
don't know have you
could you answer the question judge i
just so
you have that's not happened is that
your answer
yeah and i'm curious if you have
okay so first aside from being deeply
disrespectful
have you is just not the answer of an
innocent person
if you ask someone if they ever blew a
dog and they go i don't know have you
that person blew a dog he blew a
dog and in all likelihood
not just one either and that that surly
tone
was emblematic of kavanaugh's demeanor
throughout the hearing not the tone of a
man who hopes
to one day have the honor of serving on
the supreme court but the tone of
someone
who feels entitled to be on it and
frankly can't believe that you're being
such a dick about this
and that actually does make some sense
because this is a man who has had every
imaginable advantage his elite high
school and this is true
has its own nine whole golf course now
am i saying that someone who went to a
school with its own golf course
should not be on the supreme court yeah
yeah i think i am
yeah yeah honestly i didn't plan to when
i started that sentence but
here we are i'm going to stand by it but
the cavalry didn't just rely on
belligerence to refute ford's charges he
brought evidence specifically
a calendar from 1982 about which he was
and i know this will shock you
weirdly emotional why did i keep
calendars
my dad started keeping detailed
calendars of his life in 1978.
he did so as both a calendar and a diary
christmas time we sit around and he
regales the old stories
old milestones old weddings old events
from his calendars now look i i know
that it may seem cruel to make fun of a
man crying over his late father's
calendars but
what if i were to tell you that his
father is still alive and was sitting
right behind him that's him there and
that is why i am now
completely comfortable saying that every
christmas we'd
gather around and dad would regale us
with old events from his calendar
is the single weirdest thing
i've ever heard
anybody say and to make it to make it
weirder remember
kavanaugh just said that his dad started
keeping calendars in 1978 when cavanaugh
was 13 meaning he would have been 14 at
the time his dad had even a single
calendar
to read to his children from and an
adult man
reading last year's calendar to his 14
year old son
is literally the saddest christmas i can
imagine
other than being one of the innocent
people who gets murdered in the movie
die hard
that is literally the only other example
and and the truth is kavanaugh's
calendar may not have actually helped
him
because while he told the panel he never
attended a gathering
like the one dr ford describes in her
allegation in fact his calendar shows
at least one similar event with at least
two of the people ford named in her
letter and kavanaugh misrepresenting the
truth actually became something
of a really troubling pattern for
instance he repeatedly made this
strong claim to poke holes in ford's
story
i just want to emphasize all four
witnesses who are allegedly
at the event have said it didn't happen
including
dr ford's long time friend ms kaiser
except this 53 year old frat pledge is
actually significantly mistaking the
facts there because in reality
three of those people merely said that
they didn't recall the party as
described
and ford's friend ms kaiser did
specifically say
she believes ford's allegation and the
fourth person there is kavanaugh himself
so kavanaugh just wildly
mischaracterized evidence and that is
one thing a judge
really should know not to do it's
basically that and don't tuck your robes
into your blue jeans because it's
objectively a bad look
then then there was the fact that for
all of kavanaugh's talk of his wholesome
teenage years spent respecting women for
their friendships and doing
sick reps in tobin's dad's house his
high school yearbook tells a very
different story for instance he and his
bro
friends brag about being renata alumni
referring to a girl that they knew now
kavanaugh claims that that was
completely asexual and just
clumsily intended to show affection and
that she was
one of us which is a little hard to
believe given that a renata only just
found out about it
and said the insinuation is horrible
hurtful and simply untrue
and b if it was just affection for a
friend where's the alumni society for
amy
or julie or kristen or karen
or maura especially maura
mora most of all now
kavanaugh had similarly implausible
explanations for other terms in the
yearbook specifically those commonly
associated
with drinking or sex have you i don't
know if it's buffed or boofed
how do you pronounce that that refers to
flatulence we were 16.
let's look at uh beach week ralph club
biggest contributor what does the word
ralph mean in that
that probably refers to uh throwing up
i'm known to have a weak stomach and i
always have devil's triangle
drinking game
the term devil's triangle is commonly
known to refer to a threesome involving
two men and one woman so i'm just not
buying that
unless all your drinking games were
named after widely recognized sex acts
oh doggy style drinking game uh
you pour vodka in a bowl and you lap it
up while wearing only a dog collar
a fisting drinking game that's gripping
a shiraz in each fist and toasting the
progress of feminism
69 absolutely drinking game that's
listening to brian adams hit song summer
of 69 while
uneventfully drinking a beer on the
porch
even c-span callers were not buying this
whole drinking game defense
go ahead carl hi i just wanted to echo a
few things that another caller said
which is that a devil's triangle is
certainly not a drinking game
it's an encounter with two men and a
woman
we'll go next to mary in bronxville new
york
i i like to imagine that that guy calls
in
every day to describe what a devil's
triangle is and that was the only day he
stood even a chance of getting all the
way through his explanation
look while it may seem unbelievably
petty to give this much attention to our
high schoolers yearbook
you have to remember that to some extent
many were watching this hearing
to try and ascertain who was more
trustworthy was it the
terrified psychology professor who blew
up her entire life to relive her trauma
on a national stage
or was it judge animal house who seemed
to be sweatily making up drinking games
before members of the senate
and yet for some senators kavanagh's
poor performance was completely
immaterial
as they had already made up their mind
orrin hatch taking a break from being
pleased made the broadcast that it was
ridiculous to even ask
questions about an event that took place
such a long time ago
this is a national disgrace the way
you're being treated
there's been no whisper of misconduct by
him in the time he's been a judge
what we have are uncorroborated
unsubstantiated
claims from his teenage years now
that is clearly a shitty disingenuous
argument though although i will give
hatch credit for invoking the phrase
teenage years with the voice of a 13
year old whose balls
are literally dropping mid-sentence now
as for lindsey graham he turned his
performative disgust at the process
up to 10. this is the most unethical
sham since i've been in politics
and if you really wanted to know the
truth you sure as hell wouldn't have
done what you've done to this guy
you're looking for a fair process you
came to the wrong town
at the wrong time my friend okay
first of all lindsey graham sounds like
the least intimidating sheriff in the
entire wild west
you turn back around and get back on
your horse mr man
because what you're looking at is the
soft tender little baby face of justice
you came to the wrong town at the wrong
time my friends
the wrong time pew pew pew
baby face justice
get on your horse ride but look
second lindsey graham is not actually
wrong there he looks like a doll that's
not allowed to be within 50 feet of a
playground
but he is not technically wrong this
process was
deeply flawed but that is because he and
the republican majority
designed it that way if they wanted to
avoid a he said
she said situation they absolutely could
have but instead they only called two
people
so we only heard what he said and what
she said
a much fairer process would have
involved gathering evidence and hearing
from others
like kavanaugh's classmates in
particular his high school friend mark
judge who ford says was in the room
during the alleged assault but that is
not how republicans chose
to set up the hearing and for all
kavanaugh's emotional appeals about
wanting
his name cleared he was repeatedly asked
about whether he supported an fbi
investigation
and he consistently dodged the question
judge kavanaugh will you support an fbi
investigation
right now i i will do whatever the
committee wants
to personally do you think that's the
best thing for us to do
you want to answer look senator i've
i i've said i wanted a hearing and i'd
said i was welcome anything
you'll welcome anything just say you
will support
an investigation you've been accused of
a heinous crime that you insist
you did not commit if i were kavanaugh i
would be desperately trying to prove my
innocence in every possible way
fbi investigations polygraph tests sworn
affidavits from not only mark judge but
also all my other boys from g-town prep
i'm i'm talking about tobin timmy squee
pj
kum rug tookes merck c dubs dirty pete
fat andy
spliff dog the horn dog bonowitz bona
witch's older brother j money and
dick
you know you know character witnesses
and and look at this point let's
actually
pull back and look at the picture of
kavanaugh's character
that we now have because even if you
don't think he's guilty of sexual
assault
or even if you think that it's
impossible to say whether he is because
it happened in his
teenage years even
then there should be plenty in what we
saw this week to cause you real concern
because a key part of the job that he is
up for
is judgment and temperament and this
week we saw kavanaugh talk
over the top of senators dodge questions
and conflate
doesn't recall something happening with
deny something happened
which is again a important
distinction for a judge
not to mention he repeatedly wept at the
concept of calendars
and there was one more important moment
that i would argue is disqualifying in
and
of itself because ideally a supreme
court justice should make decisions
independent of politics kavanaugh
himself has stated
the court must never be viewed as a
partisan institution and he is right
about that
and yet in his opening statement a
document he had time to draft
and consider his tone was positively
trumpian
this whole two-week effort has been a
calculated and orchestrated political
hit
fueled with apparent pent-up anger about
president trump
and the 2016 election
fear that has been unfairly stoked about
my judicial record
revenge on behalf of the clintons
and millions of dollars in money from
outside left-wing opposition groups
now that is absolutely horrifying and it
is worth taking a moment now to note
the norm that has just been shattered
because i know that we're all basically
calloused to people talking that way now
but we are supposed to have
at least nine people left in america who
do not talk that way
and yet kavanaugh just all but came out
and said that he's going to approach his
entire tenure as one
giant case of me versus the
libtard cucks
and this this brings me to the most
basic question that remains
why why this particular
why is he the hill that conservatives
are willing to die on and i do know that
for some of
kavanaugh's most ardent supporters this
is a purely ideological issue
senators may not say it out loud but
this woman for kavanaugh did
i hope he gets in personally um
because i want abortion to stop even if
he turns out he's guilty
i think i'm still going to support him
and i hope he gets in because this could
be a good chance to overturn abortion
okay so it's fine it's fine to appoint
someone who has committed sexual assault
to the supreme court as long as they
will curtail abortion rights it's a
stance that prioritizes
human lives as long as you think life
begins at conception
stops right before a sexual assault and
then starts
right back up again as soon as that
assault is over now
obviously obviously i personally
do not agree with that but even if
ending legal abortion is your ultimate
goal there are many conservative judges
who could deliver that to you without
all of kavanaugh's issues because
purely as a judge there is nothing
unique about kavanaugh
nothing he's not uniquely qualified
trump reportedly picked him from a list
of 25 names provided by outside groups
like the federalist society whose
executive vice president
explicitly pointed out he had no
preference regarding the list
is there a leading contender for you no
there's not really not
no it's the list is really good they're
not in order
you're just saying no no no you can
throw a dart at that list and
in my view you'd be fine wow
he answered that question about supreme
court justices
like he was just asked which pickle in a
jar is his favorite pickle
i i don't know man they're all pickles
it's a pickle jar
so if it's in this jar it's a
pickle
but for some reason the republican
leadership is continuing to push
cavanaugh hard in fact on friday
lindsey graham seemed to view kavanaugh
with even more relish
i've never felt better about him being
on the bench than i do right now really
you feel better now than before
kavanaugh testified
do you really mean that or are you
afraid that if you don't say it
cavanaugh will challenge you to a fight
on a boat in rhode island
because i do get that he seems like the
type
the point is after all of this i
genuinely cannot see a
single good reason for pushing kavanagh
over a replacement candidate
because you know deep down any judge
they choose is almost certainly going to
restrict abortion rights
you don't need to choose an unhinged
partisan
with multiple accusations of sexual
misconduct hanging over him so it feels
like they're doing this just to deliver
a you to democrats
and even more directly a you to
women because
when this when this week began the
biggest fear for many
was that the committee would not believe
christine blasey ford but by the time
the week ended it seemed that something
darker might have happened
because it seemed their response was oh
we believe you
we just don't care and the tragic thing
is
she knew this was a possibility she said
so explicitly during her testimony
once he was selected and it seemed like
he was
popular and that it was a sure vote
i was calculating daily the the risk
benefit for me
of coming forward and wondering whether
i would just be jumping in front of a
train that was headed to where it was
headed anyway
and that i would just be personally
annihilated
she knew publicly reliving the most
traumatic event of her life could have
absolutely no effect on anything and yet
she spoke up anyway
it is absolutely incredible the lengths
that some people will go to
for a free polygraph test and look
look look here's the thing here's the
thing
i am i am not saying that this is a done
deal just yet
they were desperately pushing cavanaugh
through on friday only for
extraordinary pressure to force the
reopening
of the fbi investigation which by the
way may well end up
being so limited as to be essentially
pointless but the fact is
only continued pressure has even the
slightest chance
of stopping cavanaugh's confirmation and
if he does
as seems increasingly likely make his
way to the court we should never
forget how that happened or what he
represents
we certainly will not forget it on this
show you may know that for years
we've had an all dog supreme court with
dogs playing the justices from
samuel alito to ruth bader ginsburg
right good dog good dog don't die
uh good dog good dog
sit sit and don't die now
now now since 2017 it's actually been a
mostly
dog supreme court because neil gorsuch
is represented on it by a lobster
that's because his seat was stolen from
merrick garland therefore like a lobster
he does not belong there but
kavanaugh kavanaugh if he is seated
doesn't even deserve that treatment he
deserves something
that constantly reminds people who he is
something hostile
consistently up unsettling
temperamentally unpleasant and that
screams
who the allowed this to happen so i
pray
that we will not have to use this but if
we do i see no more fitting embodiment
of kavanaugh
than this
[Music]
yes that's right just as the actual
supreme court
should not have to deal with kavanaugh
our animal supreme court
should not have to deal with this
mutated carpet swatch
that appears to be tweaking on bar stops
i truly hope
it does not come to this and look there
is still a chance that we can stop it so
please
call your senators tomorrow and tell
them you do not want to be looking at
this
for the next 30 years get off the bench
you're not even confirmed yet
no i don't want to be here i don't want
to be a you big weirdo
get off that bench you entitled monster